people walking around here thinking
there's somebody because they got 230
000 followers on tick tock so humble the
[ __ ] up a lot of you say no to [ __ ]
because your humility's not a check i
still do things now that are below me
why are you guest blogging on a site
that's a 3 million alexa because
everything is better than zero i also
did a thousand interviews it feels like
on videos that got one or 19 or 137
views you understand get what you can
get take it everything is better than
zero if you keep pounding away with that
if you put your head down and ram man
and he-man style over and over and over
taking little pieces at the end of the
day you look around and you've got
something and you start leveraging what
you've got around you to build to the
next spot it's about having the humility
it's about not saying no even when
you've made it people are [ __ ]
walking around here like i'm only gonna
do joe rogan the [ __ ] are you talking
about you should do everything i still
say yes to [ __ ] that a lot of you pass
on because i out humble you